[Musik]
zdf heute live herzlich willkommen tag 6
des krieges in der ukraine und die
bilder und die nachrichten die uns von
dort erreichen sie sind und sie bleiben
verstörend wir zeigen bilder aus hartz
iv dort gab es einen bombeneinschlag
wird von einer überwachungskamera
gefilmt es ist ein angriff auf das
regionalparlament es bleiben trümmer und
verwüstungen wie viele menschen verletzt
werden oder sterben ist unklar und auch
diese bilder kommen aus archiv eine
granate schlägt in einer küche ein das
geschoss soll eine frau getötet haben
verifizieren lässt sich das nicht
unterdessen rückt auch das russische
militär vor neben hartz iv gerät auch
die hauptstadt immer stärker unter druck
ein militärkonvoi mehr als 60 kilometer
lang soll sich kiew nähern diese
us-athleten bilder sollen die
fahrzeugkolonne zeige in der stadt
selber gehen die angriffe weiter also in
kiew auch der fernsehturm wird getroffen
ja neben all dem leid und der zerstörung
hat russlands präsident putin die
russischen atomstreitkräfte in erhöhte
kampfbereitschaft versetzen lassen viele
menschen nicht nur in der ukraine haben
jetzt natürlich sorge haben angst
fürchten sich vor einem atomkrieg wie
groß ist die atomare bedrohung und wie
soll man mit dieser angst umgehen diese
fragen besprechen wir heute mit unseren
gästen den psychologen und psychiater
borwin bandelow fair ist unter anderem
experte für angststörungen später bei
uns in der sendung und zuvor sprechen
wir mit christian mölling
forschungsdirektor bei der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik und
dort experte für militär und
sicherheitspolitik einen schönen guten
abend herr müller
unsere sendung trägt er den titel wie
groß ist das atomare risiko und die
frage würde ich gerne direkt an sie
weitergeben wie groß ist es denn
ja ich glaube man kann erst mal sagen
zur beruhigung aufrufen das atomare
risiko ist nicht auch nicht wesentlich
gestiegen in den letzten
tagen was wir sehen
ist im genommen ein politisches signal
nuklearen sind primär politische waffen
dh also sind dazu da überhaupt der
politischen ebene signale zu senden auf
der politischen ebene irgendwann zu
wirken durch drohung durch erpressung
oder aber auch indem man jedem kunden
die nuklearwaffe nutzt um in richtung
ukraine aber auch in richtung westen zu
signalisieren wenn meine es ernst das
ist glaube ich die die nachricht die
hiervon von putin kommt ich kann mir gut
vorstellen dass aufgrund des etwas frust
tragen verlaufs der operation in der
ukraine er noch mal sehr klar machen
wollte über dem westen dass er vorhat
die ukraine von der landkarte zu nehmen
und dass er sich durch nichts dadurch
aufhalten lässt es ist auch nichts neues
es ist etwas was wir in der
vergangenheit schon gesehen haben schon
bei dem ersten überfall auf die ukraine
2014 hat es dieser nuklearen signale
gegeben
von daher muss man sagen es ist eine
traurige realität dass das aus einer
russischen sicht mit dazugehört wir
sprechen gleich weiter auch noch mal die
aufforderung an euch natürlich gerne
wieder fragen und kommentare an uns zu
richten bevor wir weiter sprechen aber
wollen wir noch mal um die gefahr auch
besser einordnen zu können uns anhören
was der russische präsident wladimir
putin genau zu diesem aspekt gesagt hat
und auf was das bedeuten könnte
am wochenende war es soweit wladimir
putin kündigt einen schritt an der viele
beunruhigt
befehl ich dem verteidigungsminister und
dem generalstabschef die
abschreckungskräfte der russischen armee
in besonderer alarmbereitschaft zu
versetzen
der präsident regiert laut experten
innerhalb eines so genannten atom
stufenplans zuletzt befand sich das land
in stufe eins spricht der friedenszeit
in der jetzigen stufe 2 der erhöhten
alarmbereitschaft bleiben die truppen
laut experten in dauerhafter
bereitschaft um schneller reagieren zu
können in stufe drei militärische gefahr
werden die waffen scharf gemacht stufe 4
bedeutet tatsächlichen krieg mit
nuklearwaffen
demnach sind wir jetzt bei stufe 2 von 4
wobei vier ja bereits dann schon der
atomkrieg wäre dazwischen liegt also nur
noch eine stufe was kann der westen tun
damit sich diese spirale jetzt nicht
weiter dreht
naja ich glaube das ist eine aufgabe die
vor allem dschibuti zufällt wenn man ein
signal sendet und sagt ich möchte etwas
nicht dann ist natürlich auch die frage
die sich dann stellt ok lassen möchte er
denn eigentlich wie gesagt ich glaube
dass er vor allen dingen unruhig ist
durch die sehr großen aktivitäten auf
westlicher seite wir unterstützen massiv
die russisch ukrainische armee zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt das kann ihn nicht
rechtzeitig glaube dass er vermeiden
möchte dass entweder die nato oder
einzelne andere kräfte hier stärker
involviert werden den grund gibt es zwar
nicht aber wir müssen davon ausgehen
dass
natürlich die die letzten tage die nicht
gut gelaufen sind natürlich auch die
sorge in moskau stärken man könnte ich
auch mit einer art und weise sozusagen
hier eine gelegenheit sehen ich glaube
er will die sache einfach wasser fest
für sich machen dass es keine
militärischen aktion durch die nato in
diesem gesamten zusammenhang gibt das
steht nicht zur debatte aber trotzdem
kann man ist ja nochmal einmal
versichern ich glaube von der
hintergrund das schön dass diesen plan
gezeigt haben ja der letzte der letzte
fall auf der lueg krieg so wie sie es
hier beschrieben haben heißt ja noch
nicht was denn dann eigentlich genau
passiert ist dass der einsatz von
nuklearwaffen ist das eine das 2 darüber
wissen wir überhaupt nichts und der
dritte punkt der dritte phase die die
hatten seien die militärische
mobilisierung die frage ist warum sollte
er das tun welchen grund gebe es dafür
auf den irgendjemand zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt mit einem klar warten zu
schießen
ja die frage bleibt jetzt erstmal offene
heide fragt uns über youtube wie hoch
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass moskau
beim scheitern der kommenden offensiver
auf kiew die läuft ja bereits taktische
nuklearwaffen gegen die ukraine
einsetzen könnte taktische nuklearwaffen
wir werden gleich aber mein beitrag
zeigen indem das nochmal genau erklärt
wird aber dass es überhaupt zum einsatz
dieser waffen kommt
ich halte den einsatz solcher waffen in
der ukraine aber speziell den
ballungsraum für extrem unwahrscheinlich
weil letztendlich ist es das gebiet dass
putin russlands ein verlagen möchte das
heißt er produziert ein nuklear leyen
ein gebiet das nokia verseucht ist das
später teil russlands werden soll auf
dem vorher auch noch seine eigenen
truppen kämpfen müssen der nachteil von
so genannten taktischen nuklearwaffen
also solchen die im geschäftsfeld
eingesetzt werden ist sie müssen nachher
dadurch
wird das die moral der truppe erhöhen
das ist ja auch ein signal nach innen
dass sie sich im grunde gar nicht mehr
weiter zu helfen wissen wenn sie
nuklearwaffen im gefechtsfeld einsetzen
das heißt also wenn sie die
nuklearwaffen stadt politisch als
politische waffe dann wirklich als
kriegs verfahren wird das heißt sie
haben keine andere wahl mehr ich glaube
man darf darauf vertrauen dass wenn
putin ein assist ist ein kalter krieger
und weiß sehr genau welche signale dass
auslöst und das bedeutet auf westlicher
seite auch dass wir davon ausgehen dass
sich der charakter des krieges massiv
verändert hat wir haben gerade schon die
unterscheidungen angesprochen die es da
gibt bei den atomwaffen wir wollen uns
das noch mal genauer ansehen bevor wir
weiter sprechen auch noch mal blicken
auf die situation weltweit wie ist da
die verteilung wie gesagt und welche
unterscheidung gibt es da eigentlich
genau
nach schätzungen des
friedensforschungsinstituts sipri besaß
russland im januar 2021 die meisten
nuklearwaffen
6225 dahinter die usa
die arsenale andere atommächte sind
deutlich kleiner
doch atomwaffe ist nicht gleich
atomwaffe unterschieden wird etwa
zwischen strategischen und taktischen
nuklearwaffen
strategische atomwaffen können mehr als
5500 kilometer distanz zurücklegen und
ganze regionen zerstören
taktische atomwaffen können dagegen
weniger weit fliegen und haben eine
geringere sprengkraft sie können objekte
gezielter angreifen
tja also wenn wir das jetzt alles so
sehen diese unterscheidung strategisch
taktische atomwaffen ist das eher
akademisch zu sehen oder ist es
tatsächlich von praktischer bedeutung
ist es wahrscheinlicher dass die eine
oder die andere variante davon
eingesetzt wird
nein ich glaube das hat insbesondere das
damit zu tun
welchen politischen noch militärischen
zwecken statt solchen warten erfolge
habe ich ein ein kriegs führungskonzept
in dem nuklearwaffen das ja nicht eine
rolle spielen oder habe ich das nicht
das ist der wesentliche unterschied ob
sie die waffen haben oder nicht haben
kann sich die bedeutung kann sich nur
daran gemessen nur messen lassen ob sie
tatsächlich bereit sind diese politisch
einzusetzen wir haben zb im westen ganz
klar die keine bereitschaft
nuklearwaffen zu irgendeinem zeitpunkt
einzusetzen es sei denn wir müssen
jemanden anderes signalisieren dass wir
der ansicht sind dass wir jetzt in einer
phase des krieges einsteigen würden die
tatsächlich ein ganz anderer krieg
darstellen würde das ist sozusagen ein
letztes warnsignal dafür würde bei nokia
waffen im westen benutzen das heißt aber
auch nicht sondern sie auf menschen der
ballungsgebiete schmeißen würde man
würde sie wahrscheinlich einfach
irgendwo ich sage mal in einem
unbewohnten gebiet ab werk mit einer
minimalen sprengkraft hat das lässt sich
im grunde um einstellen weil diesen
waffen also von daher werden russland
und das ist natürlich das problem dass
russland immer mal wieder darüber
nachgedacht hat nuklearwaffen als
kriegswaffen einzusetzen
dann wäre das ein thema aber wir sehen
hier noch mal die frage wem gegenüber
wenn er denn drogen und was in runde
erreichen der westen wird in diesem
konflikt nicht einsteigen dessen darf er
sich eigentlich relativ sicher sein
und die ukraine mit der ist ja bereits
in konflikt und dann ist die frage was
soll damit erreicht werden bilder damit
die lenski in die knie zwingen und damit
um das gebiet auf jahrzehnte verseuchen
dass teile der russischen förderation
werden soll
finma diesen fragt uns per mail an den
experten inwieweit gibt es den
raketenschild für ballistische raketen
und marschflugkörper über westeuropa und
den usa und welche abfangen
wahrscheinlichkeit haben diese fall zu
existieren man könnte jetzt fragen bild
das denn auch dann für atomar bestückte
raketen also wir kennen so was ja aus
israel gibt es diesen am dom dieses
abfangsysteme gibt es sowas auch für
westeuropa
ja das gibt es im prinzip das ist aber
nicht dafür gedacht einen großen nuklear
schlag abzuwehren also eine große anzahl
an raketen das wäre nicht möglich wir
haben es ja in dem ein beitrag gesehen
das muss hand dann erhebliche anzahl der
sprengköpfe und raketen hat dafür wäre
diese auffanganlage nicht gedacht die
ist eigentlich eher in richtung iran
gedacht man kann damit einen begrenzten
unbegrenzte art und weise ballistische
raketen abfangen egal ob die
konventionelle oder nukleare bestückt
sind das ist glaube ich nichts worauf
man sich sozusagen verlassen kann das
worum es geht ist ja letztendlich auch
nicht jetzt über krieg szenarien
nachzudenken sondern die frage ist ist
moskau und ist der russische präsident
ausreichend gewarnt dass er sich auf
einen konflikt mit dem westen und mit
der nato nicht einlassen kann davon
gehen wir bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
eigentlich aus denn wir sehen auch dass
der westen hier auch nicht nervös
reagiert das heißt also die nukleare
nachricht die putin sendet die ist
sicherlich hier angekommen und ist auch
in kiew angekommen wir sehen zurzeit
aber keine kriegsgefahr denn ansonsten
hätte der westen sicher nicht angefangen
entsprechende vorbereitungen zu treffen
und darauf zu reagieren
das haben wir nicht gemacht
wir haben noch einen weiteren
einspielfilm vorbereitet da geht es
darum wie die atomwaffen eigentlich
aktiviert werden dieser berühmte atom
koffer den man auch aus filmen kennt den
gibt's wirklich sogar mehrere davon und
wir geben darüber auch noch mal einen
kurzen überblick
in den usa gibt es drei atom koffer die
befehlsgewalt liegt bei präsident joe
biden falls er stirbt ist ein zweiter
bei vize-präsidentin kamera harris und
einer beim sogenannten designierten
überleben denn falls beide sterben
mit codes identifiziert sich der
präsident um die waffen auszulösen
in russland gibt es ebenfalls drei atom
koffer den ersten koffer besitz
präsident putin der zweite ist beim
russischen verteidigungsminister der als
guter freund putins gilt der dritte ist
beim chef des generalstabs der
russischen streitkräfte
das genaue prozedere ist unklar doch es
braucht die zustimmung mehrerer
vermutlich von zwei personen
also die gefahr dass aus versehen
atomwaffen gestartet werden die dürfte
relativ gering sein aber es bleibt die
frage ob sie dann eben eines tages
absichtlich gezündet werden bislang
hatte man ja immer irgendwie die
gewissheit dass keine seite den roten
knopf drücken würde sozusagen weil
irgendwie immer klar war dann würde das
auch die selbstauslöschung zur folge
haben haben wir diese gewissheit noch
das galt immer von gilt weiterhin für
ein szenario zwischen zum beispiel
russland und der nato der russe und den
usa und diese gewissheit kann wir
weiterhin noch darüber glaube ich gibt
es keinen grund zu spekulieren nur weil
das was jetzt gerade passiert
sozusagen mit klar warum dabei ist wir
haben in der vergangenheit sowohl
manövern durch russland gesehen und
nuklearwaffen eine rolle gespielt haben
also die nukleare komponente ist immer
da gewesen auch in den vergangenen
konflikten die russland ausgeführt hat
also noch mal die ukraine der fall der
ukraine 2014 auch damals sind
kampfflugzeuge aufgestiegen mit
nuklearwaffen darunter nicht um sie
optimal darauf zu werfen sondern einfach
um klar zu machen will meinen dass hier
sehr ernst das ist kein spaß es ist ein
teil der sprache die die russland
spricht und diesen teil muss man
verstehen deswegen ich kann verstehen
dass viele menschen darüber in aufregung
geraten und ich glaube man muss an dem
punkt aussehen darum geht es natürlich
auch das ist ein teil der politischen
strategie von putin weil er weiß dass
die westlichen gesellschaften mit ihren
offenen medien über solche sachen
sprechen und da im grunde genommen in
brighton in breiten teilen in angst und
schrecken zu versetzen aber wir haben
auch die möglichkeit darüber
nachzudenken und wir wissen aus der
vergangenheit dass diese sachen bislang
eigentlich kein problem gewesen sind
also von daher gibt es keinen grund da
jetzt anzunehmen es hätte sich an dieser
logik irgendetwas geändert denn das
politische ziel das ist die ukraine das
politische ziel das ist die ukraine und
die frage die von heute nochmal über
youtube an uns kommt wie würde die nato
denn darauf reagieren die ukraine ist ja
kein bündnisgebiet vielleicht noch mal
ganz kurz ihre einschätzung zum
verhältnis nato ukraine
genau die nato hat gegenüber der ukraine
keine bündnisverpflichtungen sie ist
kein teil der nato das heißt sie fällt
auch nicht unter den wieder unter den
konventionellen wir unsere nuklearen
schutzschirm
unabhängig davon sollte es tatsächlich
so sein dass russland eine nuklearwaffe
gegen kiew einsetzen würde gegen gegen
die ukraine einsetzen würde würde das
aus meiner sicht nicht bedeuten dass die
nato sich dann in den konflikt
einmischen würden das ist
unwahrscheinlich wirkt zwar unbegründet
weil was wäre in dem augenblick denn zu
gewinnen denn das zu tun wir alle wissen
um die gefahr eines nuklearen krieges
das ist der grund warum man ihn
eigentlich nicht beginnt weil das ist
der grund warum nicht beginnt weil die
gefahr sie haben es eben selber gesagt
der gegenseitigen auslöschung das ist
was seit existenz der nuklearwaffen
davon abhält sie einzusetzen
noch mal eine frage von antonio großer
per e mail wie wahrscheinlich ist es
dass jetzt auch osteuropäische länder in
die nukleare teilhabe
einsteigen also dass dort eben auch das
sind ja keine atommächte aber dass dort
eben auch dann atomwaffen zum beispiel
von der nato stationiert werden
es gibt den wunsch schon länger ein das
taten auch teil der nuklearen teilhabe
zu werden also das ist ein system in
zwei schlüssel system in dem die usa die
waffen zur verfügung stellen und andere
nato partner die flugzeuge und diese
flugzeuge fliegen der linken um die
bombe sie ziert die nukleare teilhabe
ist ein wie soll man sagen eine
besondere vertrauenserklärung der usa
aber es ist nichts wovon die wesentliche
verteidigungsfähigkeit der nato
eigentlich abhängt hier geht es um das
politische signal das von diesen von
diesen waffen im grunde genommen ausgeht
und auch da wieder es geht nicht darum
als erstes einen krieg zu führen sondern
auch da wäre es so dass von russlands
signale senden kann wenn zum beispiel
hier in deutschland oder aber in anderen
ländern auf den entsprechenden flughäfen
die triebwerke der flugzeuge an gemacht
wird und nicht nur bei einem flugzeug
sogar bei mehreren gleichzeitig dann
wäre das ein signal das in moskau
ankommt das sind also sehr subtile feine
chiffren die hier gesendet werden die
aber auf der anderen seite jeweils
verstanden werden wir haben diese
signale zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
genannt nicht nicht nicht gesendet weil
es aus sicht der nato zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt keinen grund gibt auch die
nukleare
signale auf moskau nuklear auch zu
reagieren
letzte frage hämmerling wie hoch
schätzen sie das risiko für deutschland
ein direkt militärisch in diesen krieg
verwickelt zu werden
auch das risiko halte ich für extrem
gering ist gibt zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
keine idee dass deutschland weder
national noch als teil der nato sich in
den konflikt in der ukraine einmischen
würde wir haben und das ist sozusagen
völkerrecht wir haben die ukraine
unterstützt sich zu verteidigen wir sind
jetzt dabei waffen zu liefern in die
ukraine sehr spät aber getan hat wir
haben uns aber entschieden weil es eben
eine sehr gefährliche situation ist
nicht mit eigenen truppen da hinzugehen
auch das leder vom völkerrecht gedeckt
denn wir haben es hier mit einem
angriffskrieg zu tun den russland gegen
die ukraine durch führten das heißt
andere staaten dürfen der ukraine zu
hilfe kommen weil die situation so
dramatisch ist hält man sich hier zur
zeit zurück dass die staaten rund herum
nutzen aber viele andere
fähigkeiten um der ukraine zu helfen und
russland davon zu überzeugen das ist
eine ganz schlechte idee ist hier muss
man auch mal den blick rauswerfen aus
der militärischen dimensionen die jetzt
gerade alle köpfe und alle diskussionen
beherrscht wir haben enorme finanzielle
mittel in bewegung gesetzt um ostern zu
überzeugen dass es einen großen schaden
von seinem land abwenden kann von der
bevölkerung auch in der wirtschaft
abdecken kann wenn es diesen krieg sein
ist
dem wollen wir uns gerne anschließend
diese hoffnung dass das bald passiert
vielen dank hermeling für das gespräch
christian welling war das für uns
dankeschön und einen schönen abend an
sieh an
sieh auch danke schön danke ja keine
frage also das thema sorgt für angst und
für beunruhigung nicht nur natürlich in
der ukraine auch bei uns und bevor wir
mit dem angst experten und psychologen
professor bandelow sprechen noch mal ein
paar kommentare dazu von euch da haben
wir ein bisschen was vorbereitet
zuschriften die uns erreicht haben über
instagram das können wir uns gerade noch
mal ansehen putin also versetzt die
abschreckungs kräfte in
alarmbereitschaft das war die nachricht
bereits vom wochenende und dazu eben die
kommentare von helena zum beispiel
bekommt das alles vor wie in einem film
kann es kaum realisieren lara groß
schreibt ich habe echt schlechtes gefühl
in der magengegend sandra ich kann
nachts nicht mehr schlafen weil ich
angst davor habe was am nächsten tag
passieren könnte
lewis ziller meine güte hat er 2014 auch
schon gemacht und wenn ich so raus geht
alles immer noch in ordnung also dass er
relativierend eckert eike schreibt einen
tränen smiley und malte hendrik die
aktuelle lage ist ungefähr so als wäre
man in einem alptraum gefangen der
einfach nicht aufhören will
ja das sind keine schönen worte einen
guten abend herr professor bandelow
schön dass sie bei uns sind guten abend
ja ein albtraum der einfach nicht
aufhören will wir habe es gerade gehört
da ist also offensichtlich angst die
sich breit macht auch in der bevölkerung
auch bei uns die sollten wir mal ganz
pauschal gefragt damit umgehen ja das
ist natürlich so nachdem jetzt die
korona krise uns jetzt weniger
beschäftigt kommt und wir uns auf einen
schönen frühling gefreut haben kommt nun
dieser schock und das wie immer wenn
jetzt eine neue und unbeherrschbare
gefahr droht dann sind die menschen
erstmal in panik also wir haben so eine
angst gehirn und einen vernunft ging an
sag ich mal so dass angst gehirn das
kann nicht die fakten und die zahlen und
die statistiken so gegeneinander abwägen
werden dass fans gehirn viel
intelligenter ist aber im moment hat das
angst gehören die oberhand weil diese
gefahr und jetzt zu überfallen hat und
das führt dazu dass die menschen
wirklich extrem in panik sind wir müssen
ja nicht nur an die menschen denken die
in der ukraine jetzt in absoluter angst
sind oder auch die flüchtlinge die ihre
familien zu hause gelassen haben auch
die menschen in deutschland das sehen
wir gerade ganz deutlich können nachts
nicht mehr schlafen sie machen sich
sorgen weil es eben doch nicht so man
wird das gefühl nicht los dass es uns
betreffen könnte dass wir auch in den
krieg mit hineingezogen werden können
ich lese gerade noch mal ein paar
kommentare vor über youtube ich habe
angst dass mir mein leben und meine
zukunft genommen wird von menschen die
ihr leben schon fast komplett
gelebt haben das ist ein aspekt der
angesprochen wird vielleicht also oder
offenbar eine jüngere zuschrift oder
eines jüngeren menschen zumindest
er ist das etwas was auch eine rolle
spielt bei der bewertung dieser
aktuellen situation also auch das eigene
lebensalter macht es zum beispiel
unterschied ob ich als älterer mensch
selbst noch einen krieg vielleicht
miterlebt habe oder dass irgendwie ja
noch gar nicht kenne aus eigener
anschauung wie würden sie das bewerten
na gut ich komme jetzt aus einer
generation die damit leben musste dass
wir immer von einer waffen stahlwänden
atommacht bedroht wurden über jahrzehnte
erst als die tiere stryker kam
ließ das ein bisschen nach und das hat
sich ein bisschen beruhigt aber
diese gefahr die haben wir verinnerlicht
in unserer generation
und trotzdem ist es so die jungen leute
haben eigentlich merkwürdigerweise mehr
angst das gilt für alle krisen dass die
menschen zwischen 30 und 40 mehr angst
haben als zusammen weil die leute die
über 70 sind das herz verschiedene
gründe auch biologische gründe dass
das einzige was gut ist im alter das mal
eben diese ängste dann etwas verliert
trotzdem
gerade die generation die also noch die
nachwirkungen des krieges mit gelebt
habe diesen natürlich es auch extrem in
sorge aber besonders die jungen leute
weil sie denken dass so ein leben wie
sie sich es vorgestellt haben dass alles
schön und gut wird in den nächsten
jahren und jahrzehnten das da es also
ein herber rückschlag kommt und dass man
jetzt über
schlimme dinge nachdenken muss nachdem
wir schon mit corona gemerkt haben dass
das leben
von einem tag auf den anderen völlig
anders verlaufen können müssen wir uns
jetzt wieder auf so eine neue situation
einstellen tja das ist alles andere als
angenehm maggie rosberg
kriegten glaube ich schreibt uns über
youtube unglaublich was in der ukraine
passiert trotz des wahnsinns darf man
putin nicht den weg zurück verstärken
wir können vielleicht gleich auch noch
mal über wladimir putin sprechen aber
zuvor vielleicht noch die frage wovon
hängt das eigentlich ab außer vielleicht
dem alter ob ich angst habe oder nicht
ist das letztlich auch eine tüten frage
welche erkenntnisse haben sie dazu ja
gut also angst ist normal verteilt in
der bevölkerung was ist damit gemeint
also es gibt so eine uförmige kurve es
gibt sehr viele menschen die mittel
ängstlich sind und dann gibt es eine
kleine gruppe vielleicht von 5% von
leuten die und ängstlich sind und zum
prozent die sehr ängstlich sind das
heißt also
menschen reagieren durchaus
unterschiedlich im moment ist es aber so
dass eben wirklich große teile der
bevölkerung
von dieser angst und von den sorgen muss
man muss es eigentlich sorgen denn
gefallen sind und das merkt man
tagtäglich in gesprächen mit menschen
dass da keiner
kalt bleibt wenn wir die nachrichten
jetzt sehen im moment ja wenn ich nun
davon stark betroffen bin also wenn ich
tatsächlich einer der menschen die
schlecht schlafen oder die auch sonst
vielleicht tagsüber angstzustände
bekomme was würden sie mir konkret
empfehlen wie sollte ich mich verhalten
was sollte ich tun
ja es gibt halt nicht die super tipps
dass wir vielleicht mal yoga macht oder
einen grünen tee trinkt sondern das ist
einfach eine angst jemand jetzt lernen
muss auszuhalten es gibt natürlich
verschiedene strategien die eine
strategie ist dass man zum beispiel den
fernseher und das internet abschalten
und sich in der natur spazieren geht und
wenig mit anderen leuten redet und das
versucht dieses thema einfach
auszuklammern das würde ja gut
funktionieren zurzeit noch aber das ist
nur die zweitbeste möglichkeit bessere
möglichkeit wäre tatsächlich sich
erstmal gut zu informieren dass man
immer auf dem neuesten stand ist und
aber auch mit menschen redet also mit
freunden bekannten verwandten
einfach damit die sorgen die man hat
dieses schlechte schlafen und das krumme
gefühl im magen dass man das eben mit
anderen leuten teilt dann geht es
letztendlich besser wohl uns das
natürlich aus dieser situation nicht so
leicht heraus bringt das ist überhaupt
nicht leicht das glaube ich ist auf
jeden fall klar die frage die sich
vielleicht auch noch anschluss wir haben
schon über ältere menschen besprochen
sprich man vielleicht mal über das
andere altersspektrum über die jüngeren
die ganz jungen die kinder die jetzt
zumindest teilweise auch mitbekommen was
in der welt der zeit vor sich geht die
vielleicht auch schon das thema sorge
angst kennen oder auch bei ihren eltern
erleben wie sollte man
kindern über die situation sprechen
es wäre vielleicht nicht richtig wenn
man jetzt versucht die kinder da von zu
verschonen weil die kinder kriegen ist
auf jeden fall mit 70 sehen wie die
eltern vom fernseher sitzen oder gehen
selber ins internet und kriegen mit dass
da eine grad eine schreckliche sache
läuft und das dann zu verschweigen was
da läuft werden nicht kindgerecht weil
die machen sich ihre gedanken wenn man
nicht mit ihnen redet kann es sein dass
sie eben diese albträume diese fantasien
sich selbst bilden und besser ist mit
ihnen also in einer altersgerechten
sprache darüber zu reden sie natürlich
nicht allzu sehr zu beunruhigen aber
schon alles so zu sagen wie es ist damit
die kinder also nicht versuchen sich
selbst irgendwelche
fantasien zu bilden in ihren köpfen also
das offene gespräch im zweifel gilt
vielleicht auch für david er fragt uns
per mail was kann man gegen die angst
tun mit den atomwaffen meine schwester
hat total angst ich würde sie gerne
beruhigen kann er da was machen ja es
gibt natürlich menschen die so starke
angst haben dass sie also gar nicht mehr
zur ruhe kommen gibt es natürlich die
möglichkeit hilfe zu suchen
also zu einem psychiater oder zu einem
psychologen zu gehen und also es gibt ja
menschen zum beispiel mit einer
generalisierten anstellung die ohnehin
vor vielen dingen angst haben und die
machen sich eben jetzt auch mehr sorgen
als andere das kann man behandeln und da
gibt es behandlungsmöglichkeiten bei
kindern auch die kann man natürlich auch
dann zu einem kinderpsychiater bringen
das einzig gute was man sagen kann dass
diese angst die wir jetzt im moment
haben dass die sich mit der zeit legen
wird denn wir haben ja bei allen krisen
die wir bisher hatten das auch so
beobachtet dass sich nach einigen wochen
kann der mensch gar nicht mehr so viel
angst haben und das wissen wir auch von
leuten die in krisengebieten leben die
zum beispiel jetzt in der ukraine sind
oder aber auch in carmaux leben oder in
johannesburg wo eigentlich immer
irgendeine gefahr ist dass die sich mit
der zeit
adaptieren und dann nicht mehr so viel
körperliche angstgefühle haben und noch
besser schlafen können was uns natürlich
auf dauer nicht aus der situation heraus
hilft aber zumindest müssen wir diese
angst nicht mehr so körperlich so massiv
ertragen dann vielleicht immerhin ein
kleiner trost wir hatten vorhin schon
über den russischen präsidenten
gesprochen viel wird in den nächsten
tagen auch von seiner psyche abhängen
ohne dass jetzt da eine detaillierte
ferndiagnose vornehmen sollen das wäre
ja gewiss nicht seriös aber wie wird er
in diesen tagen auf see
auf mich wirkt ja wie jemand der in die
enge getrieben ist und jemand der auch
anderen leuten misstraut also wenn man
seinen tisch ansieht wo die leute in
sieben meter abstand sitzen das hat
nichts mit corona zu tun sondern das ist
nämlich einfach die angst dass er auch
überfallen werden könnte oder
abgesetzt werden könnte das misstraut
sehr vielen menschen
und das gehört zu seiner
persönlichkeitsstruktur dabei dazu das
ja eigentlich immer weil vielen dingen
die andere menschen machen immer das
böse dahinter sieht und alles gegen sich
gerichtet sieht und das erklärt viele
seiner reaktion auch diese reden die er
gehalten hat die die ja fast paranoid an
anzumalen gemieteten reden wo er dann
dinge über die ukraine sagt über die
nazis die dort herrschen oder dass der
atomsprengköpfe gelagert werden das sind
alles dinge die nicht nur propaganda
sind sondern man muss eben befürchten
dass er sich sein eigenes weltbild
zurechtgelegt hat weil er eben nur noch
von menschen umgeben ist die eben
zustimmen und die krieg kritik kriegt ja
eben gar nicht mit also was die menschen
in der welt denken dass er im moment der
unbeliebteste mensch auf der welt ist
das kriegt er nicht so mit ja das ist
irgendwie eine erschreckende vorstellung
muss man sagen und was bedeutet das dann
auch für die verhandlungsmöglichkeiten
die man mit so jemandem hat gibt es die
dann überhaupt
man darf da nicht zu optimistisch sein
dass man denkt wenn man ihm jetzt eine
handreichung irgendeiner form
also wenn zum beispiel außenminister
sagt man solle keine us atomsprengköpfe
mehr in europäischen ländern lagern
dass er naiv zu glauben dass damit dann
das problem gelöst wäre das ist einfach
nur ein versuch zu pokern und also man
darf bei der psycho von putin aber auch
es ist ja nicht nur wladimir putin auch
viele andere die ihm seine freunde sind
eben auch außenminister lavrov der auch
nicht gerade dafür bekannt ist dass er
immer bei der wahrheit bleibt das sind
menschen die eben zu
allem fähig sind und da darf man
eigentlich muss man extrem vorsichtig
und bin ich optimistisch sein dass
verhandlungen angeht ja das sind keine
besonders beruhigende worte die haben
uns gefragt bzw wir fragen sie ja auch
zum thema angst wie ist das bei ihnen
persönlich macht ihnen die aktuelle
situation angst
ich kann mich erinnern dass ich als ich
elf jahre alt war mein vater vor dem
radio saß und gesagt hat es gibt krieg
das war 1962
kubakrise rohstoff hat uns bedroht mit
einem atomkrieg und meine eltern die ja
den krieg miterlebt hatten hatten
extreme angst und diese angst hat sich
bei mir auch festgesetzt so dass sich
also immer noch und das wird eben
natürlich jetzt wieder reaktiviert und
ich denke auch viele aus meiner
generation aber auch viele jüngere die
betreibt diese angst jetzt auch um breit
breit fragt uns ich bin relativ
entspannt und verfolge die
berichterstattung eher nüchtern
beobachtend fühle mich aber schlecht
deswegen also offenbar derart schlechtes
gewissen gibt es dafür auch eine
bezeichnung und muss man da was machen
ja das ist tatsächlich so auch manche
menschen die sagen sich wir sitzen hier
wunderbar
ausklingenden corona zahlt bald wird das
wetter besser und wir können wieder
fröhliche partys feiern und haben dann
ein schlechtes gewissen wenn sie diese
bilder aus der ukraine sehen wie die
menschen zu 100000 fliehen aus dem land
wie die bomben einschlagen das führt
tatsächlich zu einem kollektiven
schlüssige schlechten gewissen das kann
man den menschen einfach auch nicht
nehmen aber die sind natürlich nicht
schuld an dieser geschichte ist es nicht
ihre schuld sondern ist es eben die
russische regierung die daran schuld ist
ja professor borwin bandelow war das für
uns psychologe und psychiater ganz
lieben dank für das gespräch ich
versuche trotzdem mir einen gewissen
rest optimismus zu bewahren dankeschön
dann einen schönen abend an sie
einen guten abend ja und auch danke
nochmal natürlich an euch für eure
zuschriften für fragen und kommentare
das war der live stream zu diesem thema
wir freuen uns auf das nächste mal mit
euch einen schönen abend und bis dahin
schauen